a team of talented scientists cloned a
thousands of years old DNA and the child
born as a result becomes a lab rat
however no one cares about his emotions
and he struggles to find his
place Dr Julian Reid is a successful
researcher and lecturer in a renowned
University his current research includes
the history of Neanderthals an extinct
species which was similar to humans and
commonly referred to as the caveman
Julian gives a detailed lecture on
neanderthals to his student
they used to exist at least 4,000 years
ago and had a very strong body structure
with exceptional strength the most
popular reason for their Extinction is
the modern humans with their Superior
intelligence who competed the cavemen
away but Julian doesn't agree to that to
elaborate his point he tells the
students about the fossil remains of
Neanderthals discovered in 1856 in
Germany at that time different rulers
gave different theories about the
discovery but most of them were wrong
but recent scientific studies revealed
that every current human has 1 to 4% of
Neanderthal DNA so Julian believes that
they evolved from neanderthals and the
intelligence they are so proud of might
be a trait driven from the caveman
whether this theory is true or not only
an actual Neanderthal can tell that but
it's impossible to meet one but the most
astonishing statement Julian makes is
that the world's only well-preserved
neanderthal remains are present in this
University which was discovered by one
of the board members Dr Godwin Thomas
she named him William after the name of
the first scientist who discovered
Neanderthal as a separate species Julian
believes that it would be great if
anyone can find a way to use the
Neanderthal DNA to make a living clone
Julian ends the lecture with this and
goes to a restaurant to grab a drink
suddenly a gorgeous lady walks towards
him and introduces herself as Dr Barbara
Sullivan she has PhD in endocrinology
and bioengineering and has been
attending Julian's lectures to know more
about the Neanderthal she has been
working on the idea of cloning the DNA
and made some astonishing progress she
EXP explains how it is possible but it
will not be easy or cheap that's why she
needs Julian's help Julian agrees and
takes her to his personal lab he shows
him two samples of stone weapons one
made by humans and one by neanderthals
and surprisingly neanderthals is more
precise and well structured Julian
shares his idea with the university
heads and the Neanderthal project starts
right away it is progressing really fast
and the scientists are just a few steps
away from developing the Neanderthal
embryo beside the project the
relationship between Julian and Barbara
is progressing too and they have
developed romantic feelings towards each
other just a few days before the
execution of the embrio fertilization
the university director Bob calls Godwin
and asks her opinion on this project he
has asked several authorities and most
of them want to continue to the final
step Godwin patiently listens to
everything and at the end she just says
that she is not having Good Vibes about
this project Bob trusts her the most and
cancels the project when Julian and
Barbara get this news they become really
devastated and they can't let their hard
work go in vain so Barbara decides to
take a big step and volunteers to carry
the Neanderthal embryo they were about
to get married anyway so no one suspects
them when Barbara announces her
pregnancy Luckily everything goes really
well and barabara gives birth to a
healthy baby once it's done Julian wants
to reveal their successful experiment to
the public he informs Bob that he did
everything in secret and the Neanderthal
clone has arrived in the world in a
healthy body Julie is going to hold a
press conference the next day and
invites Bob and Godwin Bob holds an
emergency board meeting to discuss this
issue some suggest that they should sue
Julian and Barbara for doing an
unauthorized experiment but they can't
ignore the fact that the experiment is
successful and any University will
delightfully accept the couple but if
the Neanderthal causes any harm Bob will
be answerable so it's better to just
accept it beforehand Bob agrees to tell
the public that this experiment was done
under his supervision and with his
permission the next day Julian presents
the summary of the Neanderthal project
the public is worried about the Clone
dying and the diseases he may arise due
to mutation in response to this Julian
tells them about the security measures
they are taking no one will be allowed
to have direct contact with William the
neanderthal baby he will be monitored
24/7 by highly qualified scientists
moreover Julian and Barbara aren't
genetically related to William but for
the sake of his moral development they
will serve as his parents for from the
next day William gets caged in the lab
where he is always surrounded by several
scientists and doctors the public
protests against this experiment but
Julian thinks people are just triggered
because William didn't turn out to be a
dangerous creature as mostly expected he
is no less than a normal child actually
better he develops faster than other
human beings and shows higher
intelligence soon he learns to walk and
talk and gets a teach to Barbaro she
also treats him like her own child but
can't interact with him without the
protective suit one day William Falls
sick and begs to meet his mom Julian
stops Barbara but she can't stand it
anymore and Cuddles with William without
a protective suit luckily William has a
stronger immune system than a normal
human being therefore he recovers
quickly everything is going smoothly but
Barbara starts regretting her decision
to make her kid a lab rat when Julian
doesn't agree with her she decides to
call off their marriage and file a case
for William's custody Julian reminds
Barbara that William isn't her son but
this triggers her even more and she gets
determined to give William a better life
he is no longer a threat and nothing
unexpected happened in his body the
media has also lost interest in this
story so it's time for William to be
declared a normal child so he can enjoy
Freedom Barbara discusses this matter
with Godwin and gets full support Godwin
also helps Barbara continue her job at
the University besides that Barbara has
started working in a clinic and buys the
apartment above it she takes William to
his new house and he can't express in
words how happy he is he is not
surrounded by machines anymore and can
finally eat and live however he wants
but Julian is still determined to
continue his research on the
Neanderthals and gets the permission to
examine William once a week after a few
days Barbara admits William into a good
school at first the principal feels a
little reluctant to accept William and
asks Julian if they need to take any
specific measures but Julian requests
the principal to treat William like any
other child William grows up really fast
but the noticeable thing about his
development is how practical and
straightforward he is beside that he
also has a really big appetite Julian
also keeps examining William and helps
him learn more about the outside world
the thing that William is struggling
with is his understanding of human
emotions and manipulation but he really
loves his dad and looks up to him Julian
always motivates William to study hard
and become a great researcher like his
dad however life isn't easy for the poor
boy soon the kids in his class learn
about his identity and Bullies him by
calling him a caveman William tries to
ignore them but the bullies follow him
around they eventually catch him and
start fighting but William is
comparatively stronger than other humans
and scares away the bullies the other
kids parents take this matter to the
police and call William a Monster who
should be kept in a cage this incident
traumatized William and he has lost all
of his self-confidence this is just the
start of his struggle he secretly
researches himself and reads other
people's opinions about the Neanderthals
most people call the Neanderthals dumb
and stupid species that don't deserve to
be revived William prefers staying at
home and spending more time with his
parents but that happiness is stolen
from him as well Barbara gets a
boyfriend which enrages Julian and he
stops visiting William poor boy is
already struggling with an identity
crisis teenage hormones and now he has
to face the consequences of parents
separation even for regular checkups
Julian sends his assistant instead of
coming by himself Barbara doesn't like
Julian's attitude and asks him to be a
better father but Julian puts all the
blame on her after a few years William
gets into high school and even makes
some new friends he also starts liking a
girl named Judy who will be performing
with him in the school play she invites
William to practice their dialogues at
her house but William has already made
plans with his friends they are going
camping the next morning they head to a
beautiful camping spot the other boys
keep cracking jokes but William doesn't
understand them as he can't figure out
why humans enjoy playing with words
luckily his friends are really sweet and
also motivates him to get closer to Judy
maybe after falling in love he will
start understanding human nature in a
better way later that day the boys get
joined by a couple who also came for
camping they seem friendly and request
to join the boys they sit beside the
bonfire and enjoy the atmosphere the
woman stares at William's face really
carefully and questions his unique
features one of his friends reveals that
William is a neanderthal he hearing this
the woman's Expressions change and she
tells William to return to his own kind
the next day they go back home but
William can't get over what the woman
said to him after a few days William
gets ready to perform the school play
Judy is really nervous and admires
William's ability to stay calm all the
time this makes William get more sure
that Judy likes him at the end scene of
the play Judy kisses William but he
wants to continue it for a little longer
Judy pushes him away and also stops
replying to his messages which proves
that she is is not interested in him
anymore poor William also has to
experience how a broken heart feels
meanwhile his parents are busy choosing
a future for him his school principal
believes that William has a unique type
of intelligence and the answers he
writes are totally different compared to
known forms of intelligence the
principal advises that William should
memorize the answers so he can pass the
regular University test Julian wants him
to get the same degree as him but
Barbara wants his son to choose an
average subject and a stable career the
decision is left on William as he has
already already turned 18 Julian
explains that William is capable of more
than any University can teach him so he
should get a good degree and work in
developing new medicines using his DNA
William agrees with his father and
shifts to another house he fails the
first attempt of the University entry
test so Julian hires a teacher named
Sarah she is also Julian's girlfriend
but a really mature and polite woman she
starts with focusing on the English
language as William gets lowest grades
in it she asks William to read a
paragraph from a Shakespeare play but
William finds it weird to see the world
being compared to a stage he wonders why
people use metaphors and not say
directly what they mean why can't he
answer questions with his own opinions
why is he bound to memorize all the
pre-written answers Sarah tries her best
to help him learn but William fails the
entry test again Julian gets really
angry and scolds William to cheer him up
Sarah takes William for a walk in the
woods they share their interests and
William reveals that he likes singing
though the lyrics don't make sense to
him he loves the Rhythm when Sarah
insists William sings a beautiful song
for her Sarah had a tough childhood and
is still struggling with her studies she
is also doubtful about her relationship
with a workaholic man like Julian in
such a situation having a calming person
like William is no less than a blessing
William also believes that the time he
spends freely with Sarah is the best
time he ever had they start drifting
closer to each other and kiss William
feels the true passion of love for the
first time in his life and doesn't want
to look back when when they return home
Julian orders William to continue
studying as he has to give the entry
test again Sarah drops him at the
University and Promises to pick him up
once the test is finished while doing
the test William looks around the exam
Hall and feels like he doesn't belong
here he leaves the test incomplete and
heads to meet Godwin he wants to see the
fossil from which his DNA was extracted
Godwin also tells him that the modern
humans made up different beliefs and
moral values which forced the
Neanderthals to live in an unfavorable
environment and and they eventually
became extinct William starts hating the
other humans even more and heads to the
lecture hall where his father is talking
about neanderthals once again he is
referring to William and lies to the
students that William is proven to be as
intelligent as other humans and earned a
University degree William gets up and
reveals that it's all a lie he says that
his father should accept that his
experiment failed but in response Julian
says that William is the actual failure
this breaks the Poor Boy's heart and he
rushes out jul Julian tries stopping his
son but William clearly says that he
doesn't want to be in a place where he
doesn't belong when Julian forcefully
stops him William pushes him away but
due to his extraordinary strength Julian
gets seriously injured all the witnesses
start shooting videos and call William a
monster poor William runs as fast as he
can and looks for a place to hide
meanwhile Sarah and Barbara are also
looking for him almost a year has passed
and the public doesn't know what
happened to William however he
impregnated Sarah who Bears another
neander all child it's time for
William's species to rule once again